what's your favorite body part of a lady  try the vagina ah very good  very good  for those of you that might be him  around here hans is autistic so when  he's honest as [ __ ] it's  just comedy gold how about second  favorite female body part i think this  will tell us a lot the ass  whoa okay all right let's go three what  do you got for three  uh  probably the the tits okay great i'm  glad we got these out of the way it's  super predictable  so  i will now ask and i think we're going  to learn a lot from this what is your  fourth favorite female body part  uh the navel  [Music]  you have to now pick a body part to keep  of the women if you murdered women what  body part would that be  probably the eyes  [Music]